[Musik]
ob man das Putschversuch malterei oder
Aufstand nennt eines ist klar brigoschis
Marsch auf Moskau hat Putin unter Druck
gesetzt und sorgt für eine noch
instabilere Sicherheitslage in ganz
Europa Polen Lettland und Litauen sorgen
sich jetzt wo die wagnertruppen in
Belarus stehen auf ihrem letzten Gipfel
vor der Sommerpause sichert die EU der
Ukraine weiter Unterstützung zu
umfassendere Sicherheitsgarantien werden
auch Thema sein auf dem kommenden NATO
treffen Putin und der Westen wie umgehen
mit Russland unser Thema in der Phönix
Runde
herzlich willkommen aus Berlin ich darf
hier meine Gäste vorstellen katja gloga
ist bei uns Publizistin Russland
Expertin sie erlebte als Korrespondentin
für den Stern das Ende der Sowjetunion
und eines ihrer Bücher heißt Putins
Freunde denn Putin kennt sie auch ganz
gut Hermann Krause Russland Experte und
Leiter des Volksbundes Deutsche
Kriegsgräberfürsorge in Moskau ist uns
zugeschaltet aus Moskau erlebt seit
vielen Jahren dort und kennt sehr gut
die russische Gesellschaft ich begrüße
Anja Dahlmann Institut für
Friedensforschung und Sicherheitspolitik
an der Universität Hamburg sie leitet
das Berliner Büro ist wissenschaftliche
Mitarbeiterin im Bereich
Rüstungskontrolle herzlich willkommen
alexejus Leiter des russland-programms
der Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung und der
arbeitet vor allem mit russischen
Oppositionellen die jetzt viel im Exil
sind
Frau Glogger nach diesem was auch immer
es war Aufstand Revolte molterei sagen
viele putin ist geschwächt und ein
schwächerer putin ist fast noch eine
größere Gefahr das sagt der
Außenbeauftragte Borell stimmt das
eigentlich
das wird die nahe Zukunft zeigen
jedenfalls muss er erstmal eine große
Demütigung wegstecken
einen Stresstest für sein System das ja
auf eine Weise in den vergangenen 24
Jahren personalisiert worden ist wie man
sich das kaum vorstellen kann
damit war sondern der Aufstand die
Meuterei ich würde es nicht als
Putschversuch bezeichnen
schon auch ein Angriff auf ihn selbst
und das muss er jetzt erstmal wegstecken
das muss er in politisch wegstecken
in Russland ist ja die neue Propaganda
Linie eine Zeit der Prüfungen sei das
gewesen und diese Zeit der Prüfungen die
hat der Präsident natürlich überstanden
und steuert das russische Schiff nach
wie vor stabil und mit ruhiger Hand das
ist das Bild was man jetzt vermitteln
möchte und funktioniert das Herr Krause
wird dieses Bild auch so angenommen also
wie nimmt man das in in Moskau war wie
viel bekommt eigentlich die Bevölkerung
mit davon seit dem letzten Wochenende
ja das kommt immer darauf an mit wem Sie
sprechen diejenigen die sich für Politik
interessieren und das ist ja leider ein
sehr geringer Teil die können natürlich
in den Medien die nicht offiziell sind
also bei Facebook bei anderen Dingen
können die nachlesen bei telegram und
bei Instagram können die nachlesen was
passiert ist aber das ist ja insgesamt
nur ein geringer Teil die Mehrheit der
Menschen ist froh dass das vorbei ist
weil sie sagt was wünschen wir uns wir
wünschen uns eigentlich dass Stabilität
herrscht und gegen den Präsidenten zu
putzen das ist etwas was nun eigentlich
in der russischen Bevölkerung überhaupt
nicht gerne gesehen wird und aus dem
Grunde wird natürlich auch was Katja
Bürger hat angesprochen hat wird die
Normalität hier versucht durchzuziehen
und das sieht so aus dass Putin laufen
Gesetze unterschreibt er ist
bei Veranstaltungen und präsent er
spricht mit Businessleuten und das
kabinetttag der Ministerpräsident hat
heute auch wieder große Dinge getan aber
was man sieht der Rubel stürzt ab und
das ist wirklich ein Zeichen dafür dass
man doch nicht allzu großes Vertrauen in
die jetzige politische Situation hat als
der
russische Präsident meine erinnere sich
daran erklärt hat zu Beginn der
Sanktionen ist dürfen jetzt nur noch die
Einnahmen die gaseinnahmen in Rubel von
Westen bezahlt werden da stand plötzlich
der Euro da kann man für einen Euro nur
noch 53 Rubeln wir sind jetzt bei heute
wenn man hier durch die Stadt an den
Kiosken an den Wechselstuben vorbei geht
sind wir bei 95,3 also fast eine
Verdopplung und das zeigt eben das große
Misstrauen das herrscht und die Leute
suchen eben den doll den Euro als
sicheren Hafen und viele fürchten dass
das sogar noch weitergeht okay das sind
klares Zeichen dann immer was ich dann
am Geld doch bemerkbar macht
sie sind gut vernetzt mit Opposition
Oppositionellen die im Exil sind wie hat
man da diese Meuterei wahrgenommen war
das so ein Punkt wo man gedacht wo man
darauf hoffte dass das vielleicht der
Anfang vom Ende Putin sein könnte das
hat man sicherlich getan aber
grundsätzlich würde ich sagen dass wie
in Russland wie in Deutschland wie im
russischen Exil die allermeisten
Menschen zugeschaut haben und sich die
Frage gestellt haben was passiert hier
eigentlich das Erstaunliche ist ja dass
diese Frage sich ja auch die vielen
vielen uniformierten Angehörigen der
russischen militärischen Polizei Kräfte
gestellt haben der Erfolg dieser
molterei Bestand der gerade zu darin
dass pregorian
völlig unverhofft so weit kam wie er
gekommen ist und ein Teil dieser
ausbleibenden Reaktion dass ich niemand
aus freien Stücken ohne Instruktion aus
Moskau über den Weg stellt ist der
Umstand dass Politik in Russland in den
letzten Jahrzehnten so oft Inszenierung
war dass keiner mehr unterscheiden kann
das ist hier eigentlich tierarta und was
was ist echt ist es der echte Notfall
oder ist es in einer elitärer Konflikt
den pregorian mit Putin Aussicht weil
die eben zu einer Clique gehören das ist
das eigentlich Armutszeugnis und das ist
ein Beispiel dafür dass bestimmte
Grundannahme wird das Wesen das macht
Systems wie Frau kloge da sagt Putins
jetzt ins Krankenhaus sind also eine
Grundannahme ist
elitenkonflikte sind im Verborgenen zu
klären der Öffentlichkeit zu
präsentieren die zweite Grundannahme ist
nun Gewalt ist kein Mittel politische
Konflikte in Russland mehr spätestens
seit dem zweiten tschetschenischen Krieg
ist die innere Stabilität gerade zu
sakral die dritte ist putin ist
Schiedsrichter und nicht Konfliktpartei
und nun stellen
Schiedsrichter ob er es wirklich wahr
ist noch eine andere Frage aber so sieht
er aus auf jeden Fall aus
der Frage zurückzukommen was auch die
dissidente schon oppositionellen Kräfte
bewegt hat war das die Feststellung des
gibt kein langes Spiel für Russland
dieser Annahme dass das putinsystem
lange aussitzen und aushalten kann was
im Krieg passiert ist spätestens in
diesem Wochenende in Trümmern es ist ein
völlig neuer Phase der russischen
Politik okay was heißt denn das Frau
Dahlmann für die Sicherheit ja Strategie
in Europa oder für unser für unsere
sicherheitsgefüge besser gesagt also ich
habe so am Anfang gesagt natürlich
sorgen sich die Länder die Nachbarländer
von Belarus jetzt was würden Sie sagen
was hat sich da jetzt verändert ja also
zunächst mit Blick auf Putin kann man
vermuten dass er sowohl nach innen als
auch nach außen vielleicht noch stärker
auftritt also mehr Repressionen nach
innen aber vielleicht auch ein stärkeres
Auftreten in der Ukraine und sozusagen
dann noch mehr
eskalieren in bestimmten Bereichen wie
genau das aussieht muss man sehen
natürlich
der große Elefant im Raum ist ja immer
die nukleare Eskalation ich bin nicht
sicher ob sich das wirklich verändert
hat denn auch schon vorher hat Putin
sein politisches Schicksal sehr stark
natürlich an den Verlauf des Krieges
geknüpft es gibt international
Haftbefehl der noch mal Druck dazu
gesetzt hat das ist jetzt ein weiterer
Punkt aber ja am Ende ist das natürlich
ein bisschen Spekulation und ich glaube
da an der Stelle hat sich so viel nicht
verschwunden die Frage ist ja wenn man
ob sich Europa irgendwie darauf
vorbereiten kann dass ich Dinge
verändern
ich denke wir müssen weiter die Ukraine
unterstützen und Waffenlieferungen
Finanzen und so weiter
weiterlaufen weitermachen eventuell
verstärken mal ganz akut darauf
vorbereiten über das was ohnehin läuft
sehe ich nur bedingt noch hinzufügen
darf zu der Frage Wagner steht noch gar
nicht also es ist gerade viel was wir es
ist mehr was wir nicht wissen über
diesen Deal dass das was wir wissen es
gab es Angebot das vereinzelte Kämpfer
sich dafür entscheiden können nach
mehrere zu gehen das ist aber keine
relokation der wagnertruppe in Gänze
wahrscheinlich ganz viel anderen Ländern
auch da erstmal ist die haben ja auch
das Angebot bekommen nach Hause zu gehen
besonders bei den Häftlingen frage ich
mich was das bedeutet dürfen die auch
nach Hause oder müssen sie zurück ins
Gefängnis also ich würde erstmal noch
abwarten was das spezifisch für die
Präsenz von Wagner Angehörigen bedeutet
dafür müssen wir zahlen sehen die
Nachbarländer schon doch sehr besorgt
geäußert
Seite haben wir am Wochenende
auch die ziemlich klaren Signale aus den
Hauptstädten des Westens vernommen
Washington und zuletzt auch aus Berlin
in Form des Bundeskanzlers
dass das da in Russland passiert ist
eine innere Angelegenheit Russlands wir
wollen keinen regime change das war die
Aussage des des Bundeskanzlers also
offensichtlich ohne dass man das auch so
deutlich vielleicht sagt gibt es ja
schon irgendwie die Sorge sagen dass
sich mit der Entwicklung der kommenden
Wochen Monate dass sich Dynamiken zeigen
die zu einem Zerfall irgendwie führen
könnten die zu Auseinandersetzung in der
Elite auch in der militärischen Elite
führen könnten die wiederum die
Unsicherheit noch weiter verstärken
würden deswegen so ein bisschen das
Signal besser wenn man weiß mit Putin
wir schauen uns an was passiert aber es
ist eine innere Angelegenheit Russlands
und für Putin denke ich wird jetzt eine
Zeit des Aufräumens und eine Zeit der
Abrechnung beginnen dass die Ergebnisse
werden wir nicht von heute auf morgen
sehen es wird eine Weile dauern aber ich
denke das ist passieren würden die
ersten Signale sind da Herr Krause
ja so wir hören findet das ja schon
statt es gibt sowohl wenn man das so
sagen darf säugungswellen im russischen
Militär man will genau herausfinden
wer hat auf der Seite von Gregorian
gestanden und da ist ja auch die Rede
von
Sergej solovicin es gibt Gerüchte des
möglicherweise sogar mittlerweile
festgenommen worden das weiß man nicht
ganz genau ein General aber
der General der ja auch für seine
Grausamkeiten in Syrien bekannt war und
der dann auch mal
generalstoffchef war wieder
zurückversetzt worden ist und so weiter
also es hat in den es hat in dem
Generalstab also in der Führung der
Militärs hat es einiges gegeben
was darauf hindeutet dass man eben schon
gut und gerassimo auf den
generalstoffchef absetzen will das ist
ja auch dieser sogenannte so hatte
gregorien bezeichnet Maß der
Gerechtigkeit also er ist ja wenn wir
das alles genau wissen wir es nicht aber
ist ja wohl nach Moskau marschiert mit
dem Ziel ähm dem
Verteidigungsministerium zu zeigen wer
eigentlich der richtige general und die
richtige kriegt Führung macht die
richtige gener Mobilität und das dann
vielleicht die Vorstellung Bestand man
könnte den verdrehungsminister absetzen
und dergleichen also das ist natürlich
auch alles im Bereich der Fantasie
dieser Herren gewesen ich muss sagen
wenn man die Putschversuche und ich habe
ja nur mittlerweile schon das ist jetzt
der dritte die Putschversuche sich hier
in Russland anschaut ich habe drei
miterlebt ähm wir haben fast nie
herausgefunden was ist wirklich passiert
wir wissen bis heute nicht war
Gorbatschow 1991 informiert als er auf
der Krim war weil irgendwie einbezogen
oder nicht es gibt ganz verschiedene
Versionen wir wissen bis heute nicht was
ist 1993 beim Beschuss des Weißen Hauses
geschehen wie viele Menschen sind dort
ums Leben gekommen und ich denke auch
hier werden wir nicht immer die Wahrheit
erfahren aber was für feststellen können
ist das Putin doch jetzt zeigt dass er
sich nicht die Zügel aus der Hand nehmen
lässt und das ist etwas was man im
Westen nicht so gerne sieht man hat ja
gedacht das wäre eine Chance jetzt
in loszuwerden ich glaube das Gegenteil
ist der Fall aber er hat jetzt er zeigt
jetzt eines ganz genau dass er derjenige
ist mit dem man nicht spielen darf und
das ist um noch mal auf ihre
Anfangsfrage zurückzukommen und das ist
natürlich auch etwas was er in der
russischen Uhr mit der in der russischen
Bevölkerung punkten kann das heißt dass
da würde er Stärke zeigen andere sagen
er hat natürlich letztendlich war das so
sie haben gesagt das ist eine totale
Demütigung also die Annalena baerberg
die Außenministerin hat gesagt die
Risiken der offensichtlichen Risse in
der russischen Propaganda Design derzeit
noch nicht absehbar sehen sie Risse
Propaganda jetzt durch ich sehe viele
viele Interesse also zum einen stehen
sie vor ne also es ist ja sozusagen der
Marsch geht los Rasdorf das
Hauptquartier wird angenommen dann gibt
es die erste Runde von Verhandlungen
möchte da schon wissen kriegt jetzt ein
besseren Deal er befürchteten schlechten
Ausgang für sich er will wissen kriegt
ein besseren Deal bekommt den nicht
gehen einige Stunden und Putin wenden
sich mit einer Ansprache an alle im
Fernsehen mit den klaren Worten ist es
Aufstand ist niederzuschlagen
neutralisieren diese Ansprache wird alle
30 Minuten wiederholt sie ist ja nicht
einmalig sondern sie läuft an den ganzen
Tag durch das ist die einzige Info die
alle bekommen die auch nicht politisiert
sind wir Herr Krause sagten ständig am
Smartphone hängen wo Pregarten seine
Sprachnachrichten absetzt sondern die
allermeisten vom Fernseher und plötzlich
ohne Ankündigung am Abend kommen die
Nachricht Luca schenke heute an dir
dabei geführt nahtlos an die letzte
Wiederholung dieser Ansprache was ist
das wenn ich in Riss im System
staatlicher Propaganda darüber wer das
macht Monopol hat und wer im Endeffekt
gehen dass ich ein garantiert das kann
man weg moderieren das wird gerade
versucht ich denke zum Beispiel nicht
dass diese fulminante Rede lukaschen vor
seinen Leuten wo er denn Hergang des
ganzen erklärt je im russischen
Fernsehen zu sehen sein wird weil die
konnte der kariert wirklich diesen
gesamten Helden
heldensprache die Putin gerade ansteuern
er versucht ja aus diesem aus diesem
Wochenende hier ein Moment der
nationalen Einigkeit zu konstruieren und
zu sagen wir alle zusammen hat jetzt
allen Gedanken den Kirchen den
Zivilgesellschaft all denjenigen die
nicht da waren es als der vorausdruck
von Wagen auf Moskau zuvor was ist das
nicht wenn ein Rest natürlich ist es den
Rest die Frage ist eben was daraus folgt
ob der Westen da in irgendeiner Form
drauf reagieren sollte es gab ja
ziemliche Zurückhaltung eigentlich vor
da mal was würden Sie es ist wichtig
dass der Westen sich da wirklich jetzt
zurückhält oder gäbe ist eine
Möglichkeit
dieses diesen Riss vielleicht sogar zu
vergrößern also es gibt auf jeden Fall
die Befürchtung dass wenn der Westen
sich da stärker argumentativ oder
tatsächlich einmischt es genutzt werden
kann noch stärker als ähm ja westlich
inszenierte
Putschversuch wie immer dazu stellen und
um diese Munition nicht zu liefern kann
es sicher sinnvoll sein sich da
zurückzuhalten
das mit dem Druck funktioniert ja also
es ist der beste Beweis für die
bisherige Strecke hier das Westens der
langsam müde wurde die Ukraine zu
unterstützen zu sagen das funktioniert
der äußere Druck auf System Putin der
natürlich über den Krieg kommt für dazu
dass das System im Innern Risse zeigt
das ist der beste Beweis dafür dass
diese Unterstützung Strategie der
Ukraine bisher richtig war was bisher
gefehlt hat ist die Alternative
Ansprache an die jetzt vielleicht
langsam zweifeln in Eliten das ist
nämlich ein Gesprächsangebot zu sagen
der Druck ist da aber es gibt eine
Zukunft nach Putin und ohne Putin mit
ihm nicht weil er stellt das binär da
entweder ich oder den Haken entweder ich
oder Nein
der kann im Moment nicht sehr viel mehr
tun als ich im Zweifel auf der
schlimmste vorzubereiten und das ist
schon auch eine klare militärische
Abschreckung also all das was wir unter
Zeitenwende und sowas irgendwie
verstehen 1000 deutsche Soldaten nach
Litauen die nun fest stationiert werden
man kann immer sagen das ist
Symbolpolitik ist es in gewisser Weise
auch aber es ist ja auch ein Zeichen ein
Zeichen an unserer eigenen
Gesellschaften ein Zeichen Richtung
Moskau und das zweite denke ich was man
tun kann ist nicht müde zu werden die
Ukraine weiter zu unterstützen für die
Ukraine ist dies ein entscheidender
Moment entscheidende Wochen
entscheidende Monate der Ukraine gehen
Männer und Munition aus deswegen darf
der Westen sein nicht wanken in dieser
Unterstützung und das ist das beste
Mittel sondern gegen
die druckstrategie aber wo ist wo ist
die komplementäre Strategie weil was
passieren muss ja Leute im System in
Russland müssen anfangen sich andere
Risiko und kostenlos und Kalkulation zu
machen das ist meiner Meinung stehen sie
an der Seitenlinie und die allermeisten
haben sehr sehr viel zu verlieren und
das sind nicht nur konnten im Westen
viele haben aber auch schon verloren
durch Sanktionen und so Krause wie stark
steht die Elite weiter zu putin ist es
da ein Möglichkeit gibt es eine
Möglichkeit von ja Seiten des Westens
wenn wir mal die EU da nehmen Amerika
oder irgendwo Einfluss zu nehmen
das ist Wunschdenken das wünscht man
sich ob das passiert kann ihnen jemand
genau sagen wir müssen die nächsten
Wochen abwarten
dieser Krieg ist unpopulär auch in der
russischen oder diese spezialen
Operationen wie sehr genannt wird auch
in der russischen Bevölkerung aber wenn
man mit den Leuten reden redet es gibt
viele die sagen wir können nicht anders
es muss so sein denn der besten greift
uns an das ist das Ergebnis auch der
Propaganda und der Darstellung dass den
Leuten gesagt wird es ist jetzt die
Natur die angreifte Städte wie Belgrad
die bombardiert werden werden als
Beispiel vorgeführt hier im russischen
Fernsehen Wettlaufen gezeigt dass im Don
Bass Menschen sterben durch die
russischen durch die ukrainischen
Raketen und dergleichen das heißt in der
Bevölkerung ist eine ganz andere eine
andere Denkweise und diese Denkweise ist
zum Teil auch in den Eliten mittlerweile
festzustellen natürlich weiß man dass
man verliert aber welche Möglichkeiten
hat man wer aus diesem System und das
zeigt ja das letzte Wochenende wer aus
diesem System versucht auszubrechen der
bekommt ungeheure Schwierigkeiten wird
entweder
verhaftet landet irgendwo in einem Lager
oder was auch immer
so dass die Angst dass man da was
falsches machen könnte viel größer ist
als
die Sorge dafür dass man das verliert
wenn man was verliert dann wird man
möglicherweise sein Vermögen in Italien
oder wo auch immer da muss man darauf
verzichten aber viel größer ist die
Sorge dass man hier im Lande unter Druck
gerät und vom Geheimdienst oder von wem
auch immer
möglicherweise kontrolliert wird und da
ist möglicherweise Reaktion gibt die ja
keine haben will also der Druck den wir
uns vorstellen auf die russische
Gesellschaft auf die russischen auf die
russischen Eliten
der ist Markt möglicherweise da sein
aber er ist nicht so groß dass das
System Wand ist ist ja auch kein
Minister dazu getreten ist System der
Krieg oder die spezialoperation wird
eben in keinster Weise in Frage gestellt
das ist so ja ob sie in keinster Weise
stellen es gibt sicherlich Gruppen die
das in Frage stellen aber wenn Sie hier
mit den einfachen Leuten reden und das
was mache ich ja jetzt auch laufend mit
Menschen zusammentreffen dann sind die
natürlich ratlos und sagen wir wollen
das ist ein Ende hat wir wollen das ist
Frieden gibt aber es liegt ja nicht nur
an uns das sind so Formulierungen die
man hier zu hören bekommt und wenn sie
mit dumme Abgeordneten sprechen hören
sie gleich ist da ist es sowieso noch
viel stärker wenn Sie mit den
Funktionsträgern in den in den Regionen
sprechen werden sie doch werden sie das
auch feststellen dass man nach wie vor
zum Präsidenten steht
so Putin Frau glaube das ist das man
steht zum Studenten also da ist wirklich
Möglichkeiten dass man ja eben anders
noch mal denkt über diesen Krieg nach
außen steht man natürlich immer zum zum
Präsidenten zumal wenn der über die
Hoheit der über die Sicherheitsorgane
verfügbar allen rissen die es irgendwie
jedem mag am Ende
ist er der Oberbefehlshaber und der ist
das was man in solchen klettokratien
oder in mafiosen Gesellschaften den den
capo die tutti irgendwie nennt also den
obersten der oberste Chef der am Ende
trotz aller Probleme
entscheidet und die Macht Instrumente in
der Hand hat nun ist es seit dem
vergangenen Wochenende glaube ich auch
für die Eliten schon auch einen kleinen
bisschen schwieriger geworden denn Putin
von dem man dachte der ist irgendwie
eigentlich ewig also es schw über den
Dingen er schwebt über allem erfüllt
eine historische Mission und eigentlich
ist auch unvorstellbar dass das Putins
Leben irgendwann einmal enden würde so
so ist es ja wieder dargestellt das hat
sich geändert
die Menschen sehen dieser Mann macht
Fehler sie sehen auch die Eliten sehen
natürlich dieser Mann 70 Jahre alt er
wird nicht mehr ewig leben dass die wird
noch ein paar Jahre gehen eine Amtszeit
vielleicht sogar zwei aber die neue
Positionierung der Eliten die wird jetzt
irgendwie beginnen wir wissen nicht
meine dass wir wissen nicht ob das eine
Positionierung
ist die die zu einer neuen vielleicht
charismatischen Führungsfigur für wie
wir uns das wünschen demokratisch
modernisieren
auf einmal natürlich ich würde ganz
gerne mal auf Lukaschenko schauen auf
weil das hat ja viele erstaunt dass es
einmal diesen Deal gab mit breakoschin
Frau Dahlmann wie würden Sie die
Position von Belarus und von Lukaschenko
einschätzen wie wichtig ist der und wie
mächtig ist er weil er war ja klar
eigentlich immer abhängig von Putin
jetzt kann er auf einmal musste er Putin
helfen ja aus meiner Sicht ist eher
zumindest im Moment einer der vielleicht
Gewinner aus dieser Situation der ist
zumindest vielleicht nach Belarus nach
innen geschafft hat sich darzustellen
als eben genau der Problemlöser der der
Sachen angeht von dem Putin in gewisser
Weise abhängig ist schon gehört
wahrscheinlich funktioniert das nach
Russland hinein nicht so sehr weil die
Botschaft da gar nicht ankommt
interessant wird jetzt natürlich zu
sehen was zum Beispiel mit den Wagener
Truppen so wie denn irgendwann ankommen
passiert ob er sie militärisch einsetzt
oder sie vielleicht auch nach innen
einsetzt um dort seine Position weiter
zu stärken und was bedeutet das für die
Nachbarländer von
verstehen Sie dass Sie die das ist da
drogens und in Gefahr gibt dass man sich
bedroht fühlt also das ist eine
bedrohungswahrnehmung gibt kann ich sehr
gut verstehen plötzlich ja sich
politische Kräfte verschieben
nichtsdestotrotz scheint mir sogar schon
weiterhin natürlich ein oder Belarus
auch mehr oder weniger ein Teil
Russlands zu sein also er ist man
trotzdem kein ganz freier Akteur das ist
sicherlich sehr viel ja Propaganda im
Spiel
vor ein paar Wochen gelesen haben Luca
Schönke ist nicht mehr am Leben und es
weg oder ist also es ist die Natur diese
diese extrem personalisierten Regime
besteht darin dass Politik nur über
diese Persönlichkeit läuft sehr ähnlich
mit Russland und beide sind unter Druck
anders aber ich würde schon sagen beide
sind unter Druck nicht zu vergessen ist
vor drei Jahren haben WLAN russische
Geheimdienste in Belarus ja genau
Angehörige festgenommen und es versuchen
Umsturz versuche es gegen Alexander
lukaschen
keine harmonische Geschichte da ist
jetzt nicht plötzlich Freude
ausgebrochen weil Teile derselben Truppe
nach Belarus verlegt werden sollen also
ich bin immer dafür dass wir trotzdem
noch mal reingucken und sehen es gibt
Unterschiede und die Unterschiede
bestehen darin Alexander Lukaschenko
verbessern seine relative Position ist
aber weiterhin meines Erachtens so wie
ich ihn verstehe ich bin kein bäderbox
Experte muss ich explizit sagen und
meine Sachen ist verändert sich nicht
sein die sind Interesse wirklich aktiver
Kriegsteilnehmer zu werden er hat jetzt
schon eingebüßt dann so würdet ihr
russischen Truppen sind jetzt schon in
Belarus das ist nicht neu die Wagner
sind nicht die erste und Atomwaffen
atomwaffen sind da also es ist jetzt
nicht so als wäre das
auch wieder Atomwaffen bekommen also im
Sinne ich ich stimme von dahermann zu im
Sinne von so einem elitären Machtsystem
wo sich Positionen verschieben und
bewegen ist der kometenhaft von einem
nahezu zu Grabe getragen und vor ein
paar Wochen aufgestiegen zum
eigentlichen weisen Staatsmann und sonst
das ist seine Rhetorik und sagt ich habe
das jetzt verhindert sonst wäre das
sonst werden
in Russland wahrgenommen und jetzt auch
nach dieser ist das jetzt der der große
Helfer von Putin oder der ja wie wird
der wahrgenommen
unendliche Geschichte ich erinnere mich
noch das jetzt schon immer Gespräche
gegeben hat und als dann jetzigen fast
Belarus kassiert hätte aber gesagt hat
wir machen jetzt eine eine einheitliche
Währung gekriegt unseren Rubel hat ganz
schnell wieder zurückgezogen also er ist
einer der immer taktiert hat und der
spielt und ich denke es ist nie so ganz
eindeutig auf welcher welche Position
jetzt unbedingt hat er hat sich ja ganz
auch des öfteren gegen den Krieg auch
oder gegen diese spezialoperation
ausgesprochen es gibt Sätze von ihm wo
er gesagt hat kein weißrussischer Soldat
oder belarussische Soldat wird auch
ukrainische Soldaten schließen schießen
man darf nicht vergessen dass er die
Annektion der Krim erst unter ganz
massiven Druck akzeptiert hat zu den neu
besetzten Gebieten auch da ist ja auch
große Distanz gegangen sein Verhältnis
zu Putin und das Verhältnis von Putin zu
Lukaschenko ist nie ganz eindeutig
geklärt ich glaube dass sie sich nicht
als Freunde bezeichnen würden obwohl sie
das nach außen hin zu tun und ich denke
er wird sicherlich dafür sorgen dass die
wagnertruppe in Weißrussland nicht stark
wird selbst wenn da welche hinkommen
sollen ja angeblich auch Kasern schon
gebaut werden die haben ja jetzt keine
schweren Waffen mehr die haben ihre
Panzer aus oder das Kauf nicht mitnehmen
können oder sie werden
aber was
passieren wird wissen wir auch nicht
aber es gibt ja auch eine Befürchtung
Frau gloga das sozusagen dass da ähm
dass die wagnertruppen benutzt werden um
die Ukraine von dort aus noch mal zu
greifen
das bleibt abzuwarten ich bin mir gar
nicht sicher ob Belarus wirklich so
einer der großen Stützpunkte für die
Wagner
Soldaten für die Wagner Truppen
irgendwie werden wird ich glaube das ist
jetzt zumindest erstmal ein ein ziemlich
gelungenes Ausweichmanöver weil sich der
Kreml
und am Ende Putin selbst darüber im
Klaren werden muss wo wird jetzt was
verteilt welche politischen Interessen
müssen wir weiter waren mit Hilfe der
wagnertruppen die ja wie wir wissen in
Syrien unterwegs sind die in
afrikanischen Staaten unterwegs sind da
gibt es sehr viel
Reichtum sehr viel Profit und sehr viel
politischen Einfluss zu verteilen
darüber muss man sich glaube ich erstmal
im Klaren werden wer wird jetzt wem wann
unterstellt und werden Teile dieser
Truppen möglicherweise nach Afrika gehen
werden andere wahrscheinlich eher
weniger weil sie natürlich auch sehr
viel schlechter bezahlt werden wenn sie
sich den Verteidigungsministerium
anschließt oder nicht aber ich sehe für
die wagnertruppe an sich keine große
Zukunft
obwohl die ja obwohl es ein ganz großes
Imperium ist was der weltweit regiert
sind oder 21 bis maximal 50.000 Menschen
von denen ungefähr die Hälfte
Strafgefangene gewesen sind die an der
in die in Bach vor allen Dingen in
bachmut in der Ukraine
gekämpft haben Tausende von denen sind
gestorben also die eigentlichen Kämpfer
von denen wir
ausgehen dass es sie gibt es sind
möglicherweise gar nicht so viele okay
es gibt nicht die eine Entität
wahrgenommen sondern da sind im
Endeffekt ganz konkrete spezifische
Bataillon oder kleinere Formation die
haben ihre Kommandeure prigoren das wird
viel zu selten ausbuchstabiert ist kein
Kommandeur von Wagner sondern er ist
viel mehr dass sie der aber so medial
talentiert ist dass er verstanden hat es
gibt in Russland eine Nische für ein
heroisch auftretenden Kriegern denn das
ist wirklich das Gegenteil von einem
putinister zugeknöpft formalist des
Staats tragend nicht derbe sondern eher
sehr bürokratisch und hat das erkannt
aber zurück zu sagen ne die Leute die
zum Beispiel in den Kolonien in den
strafkologen wurden haben wir den
Auslandseinsatz Gebieten in der Regel
nichts zu tun dort sind das Profis aus
den ehemaligen sondern der Einsatz
Truppen
es ist ja nicht seine Idee das ist eine
Kreation das russische Militär
Geheimdienstes diese Instrumentes
nützlich und bleibt bestehen warum
sollte man darauf verzichten ich würde
gerne die letzten 15 Minuten noch mal
schauen auf den auf den Westen
lich wie wir darauf reagieren sollten
wir haben jetzt also bei den NATO-Gipfel
es gab beim EU-Gipfel Diskussion über
die Sicherheitsgarantien herr Krause was
müsste sich ändern aus ihrer Sicht nach
oder müssten EU und NATO ihre Strategie
gegenüber Russland jetzt ändern zum
einen die Ukraine zu stützen und zum
anderen als Folge aus dieser Meutereien
also ich sehe das ganz anders ich will
mal von dieser Meuterei wegkommen und
man muss ja die Frage stellen wie soll
das denn überhaupt weitergehen gibt es
so etwas wie ein Ausstiegsszenario sie
sagen alle und das ist ja einheitliche
Meinung auch wir müssen die Ukraine
weiter unterstützen was wird die Ukraine
machen die Ukraine versucht Gebiete
zurück zu erobern aber irgendwann wenn
Sie die hat muss sie dir besetzen dann
wird Russland wieder versuchen diese
Gebiete zurück zu erobern das heißt wir
müssen uns irgendwann mal darüber im
Klaren sein wie sieht unsere Strategie
gegenüber Russland aus wollen wir diesen
Krieg diese spezialoperationen wie sie
hier genannt wird aber die kriegt wollen
wir den über Jahre so weiterführen oder
wollen wir irgendwann mal sagen wir
brauchen erstmal einen Waffenstillstand
und dann muss man miteinander reden wie
kommt man aus dieser Situation heraus
ähm das ist ja das große Problem wir
werden vielleicht in den nächsten
Monaten auch keine großen Bewegungen an
der Front sehen wieder der eine noch der
andere gewinnt hier im russischen
Fernsehen gewinnt immer nur Russland im
ukrainischen Fernsehen nur die Ukraine
aber in Wirklichkeit sterbender
Jahrtausende von Menschen die viele
werden verwundet und was würden Sie denn
sagen was gibt's für sie ein Punkt wo
man sagen könnte dass das wäre ein ein
Ausweg das wäre eine Möglichkeit
es ist ja bei solchen Regen und
Konflikten immer so dass es ein
Höhepunkt gibt ein Punkt wo dann beide
Seiten feststellen plötzlich wir können
eigentlich nicht mehr weiter der ist
vielleicht jetzt noch nicht erreicht
aber dieser Punkt wird irgendwann kommen
und dann wird man sich hinsetzen und ich
erinnere mich noch als Minz eins mit
zwei entstanden ist wir werden
irgendwann es wird da nicht minzig sein
es wird vielleicht makuh sein es wird
vielleicht ist dann wohl sein werden wir
auch wieder so eine Situation haben wo
man miteinander reden muss und wo man
fragen muss wer verzichtet auf was das
beide Seiten verzichten müssen das ist
ganz ohne Frage und dass man Reglements
finden muss unter herauszukommen auch
dies muss geschehen Frage wann das zu
sein wird kann ihnen jemand sagen also
sein das ist der Bundeskanzler hat
gesagt wir müssen uns darauf einstellen
dass das lange dauern kann und wir
müssen es wäre wichtig dass die EU
sozusagen ein Signal sendet dass man
lange militärisch finanziell Produkt und
wirtschaftlich mit Hilfe für die Ukraine
durchhalten kann ist das richtig e
Signal
welches andere können wir senden welches
andere welches andere dürfen wir senden
was was anderes können wir tun außer
militärisch zu unterstützen humanitär zu
unterstützen
so einen klaren Korridor zu finden für
ein zukünftiges Wiederaufbauprogramm was
sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr viel Geld
kosten wird und das wird zu schultern
sein vor allen Dingen von der
Europäischen Union
und
ein Korridor zu finden indem die Ukraine
als Staat
Sicherheitsgarantien des Westens erhält
und sagen einige die große halb einer
NATO Mitgliedschaft einige sagen
natürlich die beste Sicherheitsgarantie
ist die NATO Mitgliedschaft und also die
osteuropäischen Regierungschef sagen
ganz klar die Ukraine sollte schnell
nach dem Krieg in die NATO aufgenommen
bin Österreich Irland Malta und Zypern
haben aber gesagt Sie haben da Einwände
Frau Dahlmann was wenn man jetzt auch
mal mit Blick auf diesen NATO Gipfel ist
das ein Punkt wo man sagen muss das ist
eben ganz wichtig dass die Ukraine diese
diese Perspektive hat als langfristige
Perspektive sich ja schon auch wenn man
über einen EU-Beitritt nachdenkt das
sind sicherlich institutionelle Rahmen
die da sinnvoll sein können aber
natürlich muss dieser Konflikt erst
beendet und komplett ausgeräumt sein
sozusagen bevor man darüber überhaupt
also ernsthaft nachdenken kann also im
Waffenstillstand Friedensverhandlungen
Nachdenken über eine neue europäische
sicherheitsordnung wie fühlt sich die
Ukraine da ein das ist glaube ich der
Punkt also welche Sicherheitsgarantie
kann man denn jetzt der Ukraine geben
das kann ja trotzdem politische
Zusagen geben und die man im Moment
sehen wir ja bereits eine Form von
Sicherheitsgarantien in Form dieser
militärischen und also mit Hilfe
Unterstützung der Sanktion der
humanitären militärische Ausbildung
Gerät die Ukraine ist ja auf dem Weg
eine der best ausgerüsteten und best
trainierten und Kampf erfahrensten
furchtbarer Weise irgendwie Armeen
Europas zu werden ja jetzt sagt die hat
unser Bundesverteidigungsminister hat
jetzt
entschieden dass wir 1000
Bundeswehrsoldaten an die Grenzen in
Litauen stationiert werden sollen
dauerhaft das ist was neues das ist ja
eine Engagement also so vorher nicht gab
ist das ein Punkt wo man sagt das ist
könnte auch von der anderen Seite als
also von russischer Seite als Eskalation
wahrgenommen werden
ich finde das irgendwie die falsche
Perspektive ich meine klar als die NATO
Russland Grundakte meinen Kraftrad war
genau das Gegenstand der der Gespräche
und der Vereinbarungen die ist aber
natürlich spätestens im letzten Jahr
gestorben in ihrem Geist also als
Dokument was versucht hat irgendeiner
Art neuer europäischer
sicherheitslandschaft zumindest wenn ich
Architektur zu kreieren ist es ist weg
es ist vorbei also Eskalation wird immer
dort gefunden werden wo es gerade passt
man kann es nicht von von hinten
aufsatteln und sagen welcher Schritt von
uns ist das skalatorische nicht das ist
eine perzeptionsfrage machen sie den
Gedankenexperiment stellen Sie vor in
Russland gibt es keine Veränderungen
über die wir jetzt auch sprechen und
alle anderen Länder sind dabei in der
Natur also machen
Gedanken Ukraine ist in der Natur
Georgien Kasachstan sondern danach Auto
das Grundproblem bleibt bestehen die
Definition von exzeptionalistischen
russischen Sicherheitsinteressen die
nicht zu vereinen sind mit unserer
Vorstellung von Souveränität und frei
Entscheidungsfindung dieser Länder also
das werden wir nicht ausräumen dann
würde ich das immer abgekoppelt
Betrachten von diesem Krieg weil selbst
wenn er erfolgreich zu Ende geht bleibt
das Problem an einer anderen Stelle
weiter bestehen vielleicht nicht mehr so
furchtbar und nicht in einem offenen
Konflikt aber das ist noch meine ganz
andere größere Geschichte aber wir
müssen dann so gut wie möglich rüsten
gegen Russland so das sind diese
Strategie da bin ich total bei Frau
gloga auch das Weitermachen das Rüsten
dieses Versprechen ich weiß auch nicht
wie tatsächlich sinnvoll er sich also
garantieren aussehen können denn man
muss sagen man sagt Sicherheitsgarantie
man denkt immer ein Israel es gab aber
sicher ist Garantie in einer Afghanistan
das waren auch bilaterale Sicherheit der
NATO müssen buchstabieren welche sind
das und das ist sozusagen diese
druckstrategie mindestens die
Wiederholung dessen was der besten NATO
EU jetzt gemacht hat ist auf jeden Fall
glaube ich das mindeste was man zu
sichern müsste das andere lassen mich
zurückkommen
dass wir uns intensiv damit
auseinandersetzen müssen welches Angebot
wird politische militärischen
bürokratischen Eliten in Russland
gemacht für eine Zeit nachdem vor allem
wenn jetzt das Nachdenken losgeht weil
Kalkulationen gehen so dass man Risiken
und Kosten ins Verhältnis setzt und da
tun wir gar nichts wir machen nur Druck
und das was gemacht werden muss das
Strategie
Stationierung der Bundeswehrsoldaten in
Litauen was wie wird das in Moskau
aufgenommen
aber ich möchte ganz kurz noch was
anderes sagen
oder man hat gerade gesagt dieser
Konflikt muss gelöst werden ich denke
aus meiner Erfahrung dieser Konflikt
wird nicht gelöst das wird ein
friesenkonflikt wie wir in Bayern mit
zwei haben und es wird nicht damit zu
Ende gehen dass die Ukraine die Gebiete
zurückgeholt oder zurückholt oder was
auch immer dann wird Russland versuchen
das wieder zurück zu drehen damit muss
ich der Westen auch darüber muss ich der
Westen im klaren sein das ist eine
Lösung geben wird und eine Lösung geben
muss die für beide Seiten wie gesagt
sehr schmerzhaft ist aber ich denke aus
meiner Erfahrung heraus da wird es
darauf hinauslaufen ich würde ganz gerne
mal auf eine andere Ebene kommt Frau
Glory sie haben in den 80er 90ern in
Moskau Moskau viel gearbeitet auf der
menschlichen Ebene wenn Sie jetzt denken
wie könnte eine Zukunft vom von uns im
Umgang mit Russland eigentlich sein
welche Gedanken haben sie dazu wenn man
jetzt mal nicht über die militärische
Ebene redet wenn man sieht wie viele
Menschen in Russland verlassen haben all
das wo denken sie
Ansatz wo man wieder zu irgendeinem
miteinander finden könnte Förderung all
dessen aldera die ins Exil gehen mussten
das bedeutet auch
großzügig Großzügigkeit
Großherzigkeit wenn es um humanitäre
Visa geht wenn es um ein Leben eine neue
Existenz geht die sich Menschen in
außerhalb Russlands also Russinnen
außerhalb Russlands aufbauen müssen
nicht nachlassen in unserem Interesse an
diesem Land in unserer Neugier im besten
Sinne irgendwie das Wortes verstehen zu
wollen was in diesem immer weiter
abgeschotteten Land damit passiert
und sich mit der Frage beschäftigen die
mich so ein klein wenig umtreibt auch am
ändert sich mit diesem Wochenende und
mit diesem fortschreitenden Krieg ändert
sich vielleicht sogar als so ein
bisschen etwas in den Seelen der
Menschen in alle ja in alle wissen
dieses System ist eine gigantische Lüge
alle wissen es alle wissen wie korrupt
das System ist wie sehr es die Menschen
irgendwie ausnutzt
dass es nicht funktioniert das ist nicht
effizient ist das ist ökonomisch immer
weiter ins Hintertreffen irgendwie Gerät
und doch vereinen sie sich sammeln sie
sich Sorgen hinter diesem System
identitätsstiftend mit
Opferbereitschaft patrioletta immer noch
als Bedrohung empfinden
Opferbereitschaft Patriotismus diesen
Verweis auf die glorreiche imperiale
Vergangenheit ja auch auf die Bedrohung
durch den Westen das hat bislang ganz
gut funktioniert auch wieder die mir
Putin und die frage mich ob das nicht
beginnend zu sagen so leise Risse zu
bekommen
so zu Oppositionellen sowohl in Russland
als auch die im Exil sind also wo sehen
sie eine Möglichkeit wenn sie wenn man
sie haben gesagt wir müssen über eine
Strategie nachdenken auch wie wir mit
diesem Land umgehen also auf dieser
zwischenmenschlichen Ebene wo sehen Sie
denn da Möglichkeiten ja der russischen
Regierungen zur Zeit fehlt jegliches
Verständnis aber es gibt auch kein
Angebot
eines Gesprächs über Zukunft mit der
eigenen Bevölkerung Zukunft findet nicht
statt in der Regierungskommunikation die
ist entweder sehr technisch und
technokratisch über Indikatoren aber es
gibt keine zukunftserzählung die gesamte
russische Politik ist zurzeit
vergänglich Vergangenheit und ich glaube
wenn wir fantasieren jetzt wenn es
diesen Tag gibt wo es wieder geht müsste
müsste Deutschland die Bundesrepublik
auch mit ihrer
opfertäter Erfahrung als Gesellschaft
ehrlich gesagt
den Gesprächspartner neu knüpfen und
sagen jetzt wird es aber wirklich people
to people und jetzt wird es wirklich
Visa frei für unter 25-jährige steht im
Koalitionsvertrag der Ampel natürlich
war das vor dem Krieg aber ich will noch
mal darauf hinweisen was man sich noch
mal überlegt hat was funktioniert würde
70% aller russischen Russen haben keine
Reisepass
von den 30 die einen haben war ein
Drittel je in Europa es gab nie die
historische Gelegenheit
klar
wir könnten alle dahin wenn wir dieser
haben und das machen wollen aber in der
andere Richtung natürlich nicht und es
geht um das neu begründen der der
gesellschaftlichen Kommunikation das was
mit anderen Gesellschaften funktionieren
wird mit Ukraine wird es funktionieren
Ukraine hat eine wundervolle Russland
wird natürlich überhaupt gar nicht mehr
funktionieren über Jahrzehnte Zeit ja
eine sehr sehr lange Zeit herr Krause da
geben wir das letzte Wort nach Moskau
gibt's so ein Punkt wo sie sagen das
würde ich mir von Deutschland wünschen
wenn ich in die Zukunft gehe in dem
Verhältnis mit Russland
ja ich würde mir wünschen dass der
Dialog nicht
der ist ja fast völlig abgebrochen dass
der Dialog wieder aufgenommen wird dass
es wieder Städtepartnerschaften gibt das
habe ich als ein großen Fehler angesehen
dass man das sofort unterbunden hat das
ist wieder Austausch der Universitäten
gibt auf wissenschaftlicher Ebene denn
gerade da sitzen ja die Leute die eben
mit diesem System nicht einverstanden
sind die jungen Leute die würden gerne
wieder nach Deutschland reisen und an
die Uni gehen und da gibt es im Moment
leider Schranken das ist fast für die
unmöglich geworden und das wünsche ich
mir einfach das oft
zivilgesellschaftlicher Ebene der
Kontakt wieder aufgenommen wird weil ich
weiß es wird von russischer Seite also
von den russischen Menschen wird das
sehr befürwortet die nicht nach wie vor
Menschen ein gutes Verhältnis zu
Deutschland zu haben das höre jeden Tag
und ich treffe ganz viele Menschen die
Deutsch sprechen und die sagen wir
müssen wieder zueinander finden wäre
schön wenn das
gewinnen könnte wenn der Krieg beendet
würde von Logo vielen Dank Herr Krause
vielen Dank noch Moskau und Frau da man
ganz herzlichen Dank und ganz herzlichen
Dank ihnen fürs Interesse an der Phönix
Runde bis dann tschüss
[Musik]